já está gravando estará com a galera meu
nome é o início nunes está começando
mais um
o início nunes roda vinheta padrasto ea
galera que estava tudo bem com vocês e
estou aqui gravando na potycabana vocês
podem ver eu fiquei muito ri tão rico
que eu comprei pode amanhã pra mim essas
pessoas são todos seguranças na malhação
não estão sendo pagos pra isso celas
meninas a lei também posso entender
garotinha vou adicionar no facebook eu
sou muito fã de futebol e não sou um
cara fanáticos indico o estádio de
quebra a torcida adversária passa pela
não isso não só de fazer mas eu gosto
muito boa gente estabilidade e ordem
gente que joga bola de verdade eu
percebi que e seguir eu percebi que nos
dias de hoje o futebol tem mudar demais
vai mudar demais hoje em dia o pessoal
joga o futebol está fingindo de mais vai
esquecer de jogar bolas paradas ligado à
quinta às expectativas sair pro jogo que
você pretende fazer como é que vai ser
isso é o bastante expectativa boiko jogo
entrou e não muito duras e mano e vou
fazer a orientação do técnico animador
e só pra nós e nós aqui eu tenho raiva o
rápido jogador que tá aí um jogo todinho
pacaembu
o que eu tô mais raiva de jogador o ator
que tem jogador que atualmente está
ligado tipo para fingir com ninguém
é o que eu tô mais raiva mesmo é quando
o cara fingir discaradamente pela volta
do final de maio no recife
an a ai ai alcance a montável
ok tá aqui pra mim tem jogador que
merece ganhar mostre tão bem que ele
atua mas também aquela parte que a
futebol tem você entende passo que lá é
verdade futebol tem muita coisa que você
não entende o exemplo de vôlei
como é que um gol de voleio porque o
jogador de vôlei se o boné de vôlei mas
nesse mundo de vôlei realmente funcionou
de vôlei
o gol de bicicleta
então é isso que você quer ser jogador
de futebol por favor não finge jogue
bola você está vendo pelo facebook já dá
algum curtir jack kerouac gostei de você
gostou e comenta aqui em baixo o que
você acha mais distante futebol e o que
você gosta de você não gosta do futebol
é a primeira vez que está havendo aqui
se aplica logo em inscrever-se toda vez
que tiver um vídeo no vimeo
você vai saber essa música pra você que
o destino da tanga se você quiser uma
dessas aqui é nesse site aí e é isso aí
o garotinho muito obrigado e falou
ai ai ai ai ai